before the video gets started I will be
doing another giveaway as we reach 300
subscribers so thanks to you guys keep
it up this 1 mil is donated from town
CER so thanks to him shout out to him
and the way to enter this is leave your
RSN in the comment section leave a like
on the video and subscribe to my channel
and then I will do a randomizer to pick
the winner and then I'll give them the
money in game all right let's get
started into the
[Music]
video
need that to
the I get those gops every what is Up
Guys in today's video I'm be showing you
another loot video from another 100
chest that I did and then I'm be showing
you at the end of it all the items I got
and all the runes and all the coins and
all the miscellaneous items and then at
the end of this video I will be doing
the math of my other video with the 100
barrels chest combined with this 100
barrels chest and then I'll be doing a
grand total of how much we made so you
guys can get a better average let's get
into the chest
[Music]
[Applause]
so I finished my second 100th barrel
chest so 200 grand total I was just over
200 because I did some other chests
before I started making these videos but
I was super excited now it's time to
show you guys the items I got from the
barrels chest
[Music]
[Applause]
so now we will get into the calculations
so for the runes total keep in mind the
red is the new 100 chest that you guys
just saw and the white on the left side
is the old ones from my original video
so from my original video I had 5,249
death runes
9,345 chaos runes 3,498 blood runes
19654 mine runes and then for my new 100
I had
7,363 death runes
11,26 chaos runes 3,268 blood runes and
28,6 189 M runes so total death runes
for 200 chest I had
12,612 total for the chaos runes
20551 total for the blood runes
67,68 total for the Mind runes
48343 for my bolt / miscellaneous again
the red is the new chest and the white
is the old chest so my old chest I had
2,718 bolt racks I had one Loop half I
had two to TS and I had one Elite clue
scroll for my new ones I had one Dragon
medh Helm in the top left 3,437 bolt
racks two Loop Hales zero tooth Hales
and zero clue Scrolls that makes our
totals for the Dragon medhel one for the
bolt racks 6, 1555 for the loop Hales
three for the tooth Hales two and for
The Clue Scrolls one now for the barrel
pieces in the original video of The 100
barrels chest we got one too plate legs
one too's plate body one to hammers one
verx brassard one verac plate skirt two
carros plate skirts and one Guth and War
spear for the new 100 we got one Tac
body one Carol top one Aram robe skirt
one verac helmet and one Carol skirt and
the only numbers that change is the
too's body for the total we got two of
them and for the Carol skirts we got
three the rest of them on the screen we
got one now we will do some math so for
the runes total the original 100 we made
1,511 712 12 on the death runes we made
9625 35 for the chaos runes
87654 for the blood runes and 58,60 for
the mine runes those are all the
original runes and we made a total of
3,497 for the new 100 chest we made 1,
18628 39 on the death runes
1,131 186 on the chaos runes
75888 for the blood runes
8667 for the M runes for a total of
3,786 th000 and so the grand total of
both of these combined for the 200 we
made
7,195 713 and for those of you who are
curious divided by 2 is
3,597 856 that's the average you made
per 100 chests so for the bolt SL
miscellaneous for the original 100 we
made
17676 on the bolt racks 8 93 on the loop
Hales
34,600 on the tooth Hales and na on the
clue scroll because you can't sell it
and we have not completed that yet for
the new 100 we made
225,000 for the tooth halfes zero for
the clue Scrolls and
59,2 for the dragon medel that's a total
of 30
1,974 and the total for the original was
22,43 and the grand total of 200 chest
522,000 49 and if you're interested
divided by 2 is
261,000 chest now for the barrows pieces
for the original it made 287,000 on the
tox plate legs 247,000 on the toox plate
body 100,000 for the toox hammer 450,000
for the verac brard 1, 359,000 for the
verac plate skirt 205,000 for the Carrol
skirt 2, 80,000 for the goth and
warspear for a grand total of 4,933
th000 and the Carl skirt was times 2 so
keep that in mind that was 410,000 and
for the new 100 we made
1,761 167 on the carols top
1,3,5 69 * 2 on the arams Rob skirt
3874 for the verac helmet
177,178 for the Carol plate skirt
221,00
485,000 total was
9,487 8 for 200 chest and again divided
by 2 is
4,793 so that's per 100 chest so now for
the totals for the runes we had
7,195 713 for the b/ miscellaneous we
made 522,000 n for the pieces we made
9,418 78 for the coins we made 164,165
415 so that's how much we made in 200
chest and divided by 2 is 8 m 6 50, 206
so that's per 100 chests now for some
calculations so on average you have a 1
in6 chance of getting a barrels item
which is a
0625 and the result that we got from 200
chest was 14 items in 200 chest so
that's a 07 so we're slightly above
average and the grand total
17,345 divided by 200 chests equals
8652 per chess so that's how much money
we make per chest and the grand total
17,300 415 divided by 20 hours that's
how long it took me to do 200 chess on
average was
865,000 so that's how much money you
make per hour and that's not counting
supplies I hope you guys like this video
it took me a lot of time so go ahead and
leave a like if you like this video
leave a comment if you have any ideas
for new videos and go ahead and
subscribe to my channel for more content
again for the 1 million giveaway make
sure to leave your RSN in the comment
section leave a like on this video And
subscribe to my channel to enter the
giveaway all right guys thanks for
watching stay tuned for my next video
n